Vous avez sans doute tous déjà entendu cette
phrase : « On ne naît pas femme, on le devient"
tirée du livre Le Deuxième Sexe de Simone de Beauvoir et qui bannit tout déterminisme
dans l’identité sexuelle.
En clair, on différencie par là le sexe
biologique du genre.
Si cette thèse est tout à fait recevable
pour le sexe féminin, elle est également valable
pour le sexe opposé : « on ne naît pas
homme, on le devient ». Pour quitter l’enfance
et devenir un homme adulte beaucoup de sociétés
ont mis en place ce qu’on appelle des « rites
de passage ».
Ces rites, étant souvent spectaculaires,sont
devenus un objet d’étude très prisé par
les anthropologues.
C’est Arnold Van Gennep qui le premier,
en 1909, utilisa l’expression « rites de
passage ». Il remarqua qu’ils se structuraient
toujours de la même manière, en trois temps
: une mise à l’écart des individus concernés
par le rite ; la cérémonie à proprement
parler ; et la réintégration, qui marque
l’obtention d’un nouveau statut social.
Mais, plutôt que de vous lister une multitude
de rites en mélangeant les populations, les
époques et les zones géographiques je vais
me centrer sur les rites des Baruya de Papouasie
Nouvelle-Guinée.
Rentrons dans le vif du sujet : Comment devient-on
un homme chez les Baruya ?
Pour répondre à cette question je vais m’appuyer
sur les travaux de l’anthropologue Maurice
Godelier, qui a passé 7 années aux côtés
de cette population à partir de 1966.
Concrètement, chez les Baruya, un homme est
un homme avant tout s’il sait se battre,
s’il est un guerrier : en clair, il ne faut
pas avoir peur de tuer.
Les rites et les initiations sont des étapes
que les jeunes vont découvrir petit à petit
durant plusieurs années, en commençant vers
l’âge de 9 ans, en les séparant du monde
féminin, c’est-à-dire de celui de leur
enfance et en les plaçant tout d’abord
dans des maisons particulières que l’on
appelle des « maisons des hommes ».
Ces rites, parfois difficiles, leur permettront
d’obtenir un nouveau statut social,
celu d’homme justement.
Qu’est-ce-qu’un rite ?
Un rite c’est ce qui permet à la société
de se structurer, de donner des rôles aux
individus.
Par exemple, concernant la place de la femme
et de l’homme chez les Baruya et bien il
faut comprendre que c’est l’homme seul
qui est considéré comme un géniteur, c’est
son sperme qui fait les fœtus.
Dans cette organisation, la femme n’est
pas génitrice, elle n’est qu’un sac.
c’est pas moi qui le dit, c'est d’ailleurs le nom que porte son utérus.
Les croyances Baruya précisent que durant
la période de gestation, c’est le soleil
qui complète, par ses rayons, le travail
de l’homme dans le ventre de la femme.
Comme je le disais avant, les premières initiations
commencent lorsque les garçons ont entre
9 et 10 ans.
Ils sont tous séparés violemment du monde
féminin pendant plusieurs semaines : des
hommes avec des branches épineuses viennent
chercher l’enfant et le flagellent.
Un garçon n’est jamais seul durant son
initiation, il est accompagné d’un parrain,
un homme adolescent encore vierge qui suivra
tous les rites.
Il y a beaucoup de cris, de pleurs.
Ce qui peut facilement passer pour de la perversité
dans notre culture, est pensé comme essentiel
pour faire accéder les garçons au rang d’hommes,
c’est la première épreuve.
Plus tard, vers 12/13 ans et jusqu’à 15
ans ils peuvent commencer à porter des flèches
et sont habillés comme des hommes ; c’est
une étape importante, leur tenue était jusqu’alors
ouverte au niveau des fesses pour rappeler
leur statut d’enfant
qui sont généralement entièrement nus.
Cette nudité partielle est faite pour donner
honte face aux petites filles et pour les empêcher
de rester avec elles.
L’habillement matérialise le changement
de statut.
Les 20 ans marquent une rupture forte
dans la vie d’un jeune homme.
Car c’est à 20 ans que, sans en avoir le
choix, il quitte la maison des hommes pour
se marier avec une femme qu’il n’a pas
choisie non plus.
L’amour n’a rien à voir avec le mariage
: chaque homme a l'obligation de
se marier et d’avoir des enfants.
Car ce sont les enfants qui rendent stable une famille
pas par les sentiments !
En début de vidéo, je vous disais qu’il
faut, pour être un homme, être un guerrier
et pour cela se couper du monde des femmes.
La seconde préoccupation chez les Baruya,
et qui est au fondement de l’organisation de la société
c’est qu’il faut refaire
les garçons, c’est-à-dire les réenfanter sans les femmes.
Pour Maurice Godelier
cela veut dire qu’il faut réaffirmer l’idée,encore
une fois, que la femme n’est pas génitrice.
Comment refaire des hommes sans les femmes
?
A cette question,l’anthropologue aura attendu
plusieurs années la réponse que je vais
tenter de vous expliquer.
Les enfants deviennent des hommes par des
pratiques homosexuelles.
A l’intérieur des maisons des hommes, les
initiés de 20 ans, qui sont les parrains
des plus petits, n’ont jamais eu de rapports
sexuels (c’est interdit).
Ils ont un sperme pur.
Ce sperme, ils le donnent à boire aux petits.
Inséminer des substances purement masculines
dans le corps des petits permet aux Baruya
de refaire des hommes sans les femmes !
Mais comment comprendre de telles pratiques ?
Parce que c’est pas 50 nuances de grey en
Papouasie Nouvelle-Guinée.
Pour nous occidentaux, le recours à notre
imagination est sans doute nécessaire : comprenez
ça comme la construction d’un guerrier
supérieur aux femmes qui a ainsi éliminé
de son corps masculin tout ce qu’il y a de féminin.
Poursuivons l'explication
Durant leur première nuit de couple les mariés suivent également des rites
La femme doit faire une
fellation à son mari.
C’est un acte très important, qui n’est
pas une simple expression de désir ou d’érotisme.
Il signifie qu’à partir de ce moment, l’homme
ne pourra plus mettre son sexe dans la bouche
d’un garçon (donc ne pourra plus participer
aux pratiques homosexuelles expliquées avant).
Toujours dans cette logique de faire de l’homme
un géniteur, le lait maternel lui aussi
doit être masculin et la fellation permet
de transformer le lait maternel.
Pour les Baruya, le lait maternel c’est
du sperme transformé !
Ce n’est pas la seule fois où le sperme
sera partie intégrante des rites.
Avant le mariage, l’homme part dans la forêt
auprès d’un arbre sacré.
Ce rite est secret et les femmes ne sont pas
censées le savoir
mais elles le savent très bien, dans un village tout ce sait c’est
bien connu.
Cet arbre a une sève blanche qui ressemble
beaucoup au sperme.
L’homme initié se poste devant l’arbre
en hurlant le nom de sa fiancée puis il crie
« ce n’est plus ton père qui te possède,
c’est moi ».
A ce moment précis, on est en droit
de dire que les hommes dominent totalement
les femmes et que les Baruya sont des gros machistes…
Si Maurice Godelier était resté moins longtemps
sur place, c’est sans doute le constat final
qu’il aurait fait.
Cependant, au fil des discussions avec les
Baruya, et notamment à propos des croyances
sur lesquelles reposent ces pratiques, des
explications plus nuancées ont pu être proposées
pour comprendre d'où vient cette domination masculine.
Malgré tout ce que l’on a pu voir à travers
les rites, les hommes occupent pourtant une
place secondaire par rapport aux femmes dans
les mythes.
On raconte que les femmes étaient à l’origine
dotées de pouvoirs, d’arcs et de flutes
sacrés qui leur assuraient une suprématie
sur les hommes.
Elles étaient également créatrices mais
elles mettaient le désordre.
Les hommes sont venus et ont mis de l’ordre par des rites !
Ils ont donc créé les rites pour empêcher que les femmes reprennent
leurs pouvoirs !
par peur, ils dominent les femmes !
Beaucoup d’hommes dominent les
femmes parce qu’ils les craignent.
Cette idée du matriarcat mythique ou originel
se retrouve dans de nombreuses sociétés,
pensez aux Amazones des Grecs par exemple,
mais toutefois, dans la
réalité,
ce sont bien les hommes qui ont le pouvoir.
Au-delà du mythe, il faut comprendre les
rites de la façon suivante : pas d’initiation,
pas de mariage ; pas de mariage ; pas d’enfant,
… : le système est bouclé !
Les mères veulent absolument que leurs enfants passent
toutes ces étapes.
Les garçons comme les filles d'ailleurs.
Donc c'est vraiment une forme d'éducation collective.
Les rites de passages sont indispensables
au bon fonctionnement de la société, leurs
rôle est politique et religieux.
Depuis les années 60 les pratiques chez les
Baruya se modifient, notamment depuis l’arrivée
des missionnaires qui tentent de bannir ces
rites au profit du christianisme.
Dans toutes les sociétés papoues, des changements
se sont opérés : les jeunes gens sont partis
travailler en plantations, il y a eut l’arrivée
des armes à feu et de l’alcool.
Si bien qu’aujourd’hui beaucoup de Baruya
sont tentés de se conformer à une certaine
idée de la modernité.
Eux-mêmes le disent « Etre moderne c’est
suivre Jésus et faire du business » et pour
cela ils suivent le modèle américain !
A terme, les rites que Maurice Godelier a décrits
vont probablement disparaître complètement
et les occidentaux opposés à la maltraitance
des enfants durant l’initiation s’en réjouissent
plutôt.
En revanche, les anthropologues qui tentent
de démêler ces pratiques pour parvenir à
comprendre un peu mieux tout ce qui peut faire
une société humaine ont tendance à s’en
alerter.
Lorsqu’on étudie des cas où les valeurs
culturelles entrent en conflits comme dans
ce que je viens d’exposer, ou dans les sociétés
qui pratiquent la scarification, l’excision,
et bien ça pose la question du positionnement
de l’observateur.
Lévi-Strauss qui aimait comparer l’ethnologue
à un astronome, dresse un parallèle débattu,
il dit : « quand un astronome observe une
étoile qui meurt, il n’est pas triste,
il observe."
Cela serait valable selon lui pour les
sociétés et les individus, il faudrait en
somme rester distancé et neutre, sans s’impliquer
directement dans le devenir de ce qui est
avant tout un objet d’étude.
Cet avis est bien évidemment très contesté
en anthropologie, mais il met le doigt sur
un problème majeur,
jusqu’où doit-on respecter
les coutumes d’un peuple et à quel point
doit-on les préserver si tant est qu’il
faille les préserver ?
Cet épisode est terminé, j'espère qu'il vous a plu
dans tous les cas, n'hésitez pas à aller consulter les sources en barre d'info
j'y ai mis des liens vers des conférences données par Maurice Godelier
qui vous retrace l'intégralité de son terrain
Parce ce que là j'ai fait des choix dans les rites que je vous ai présentés
j'ai pas pu tout vous présenter.
Avant de se quitter, je tiens à remercier les tipeurs
grâce à vous j'ai pu investir dans de l'éclairage et dans un nouvel objectif
et sans vos dons ça n'aurait pas été possible
donc vraiment un grand merci
j'en profite pour les autres pour vous rappeler que la chaîne a un compte Tipeee
Tipeee c'est une plateforme de financement participatif sur laquelle vous pouvez aider la chaîne
à se maintenir financièrement.
Je vous remercie et je vous dis à la prochaine
Salut !